[Music]
i would love to ask a question that is
specific to you and this might be a bit
of a left turn but i think it would be
i'm personally very curious
if we could go
back to
your brother's suicide and i know it's
probably not the easiest thing to talk
about but
that is a
i mean it's it sounds like uh
it's hard for me to conceive of a of a
larger
event at least in the vicarious trauma
category
what are the things
that helped the most in terms of coming
to terms with that or healing from that
to the extent that you have
sure
i mean i'll start by saying
you know i had no mental health
education or experience at the time
so my initial responses like weren't
very healthy right i mean i felt like oh
it's my fault i should have known
right i should have been a better
brother right i was probably fairly
depressed myself and drinking too much
and all sorts of other things that that
i was still like going along with life
but feeling very oppressed
and and feeling oppressed not just
externally but inside right so so this
idea that trauma changes how we think
about ourselves and then we're trying to
recognize that it's like trying looking
in the mirror and saying is that me but
you don't really remember what you
looked like yesterday right so that was
very scary and and a lot of the ways in
which i handled it were not helpful or
healthy
so ultimately when i think how did i get
through that
it was
interconnections with other people were
absolutely indispensable that there were
people around me who cared about me who
were then reflecting back to me like no
you're a good person and a terrible
tragedy has happened to you
which is like very helpful because they
they could see me
because they they knew me and they knew
me before the tragedy it was me who
couldn't see me
and they were basically communicating
you know
this something awful has happened but
you're the same person you were before
and that's a capable person and a caring
person right and that was immensely
helpful to me and and some of that was
through friends and family and also i
went and got some psychotherapy which
people weren't really doing like where i
grew up you know people didn't go to
therapy right where did you grow up
outside of trenton new jersey
and it just wasn't in the culture so for
me going and getting therapy even was
like something do i feel embarrassed
about that is it do you know do healthy
people ever do that is that just for
crazy people like that you know that was
that was how it was thought of so i had
to do something that i think did have
some bravery to it of saying like hey
let me be honest with myself is i'm not
doing okay
and and i'm getting help from people
right and there are people who care
about me but there's professional help
too
and i you know i just found a therapist
and she was very very helpful
to me in that basic grounding way
so
the impact of others was so helpful
because otherwise i i think i probably
there's a good chance i would have never
seen myself the same way again
in in a way that could have just been
worse and worse and worse and that's
ultimately what led me to is this kind
of come to a full stop and and look at
how it was handling my life
and and like their silver linings i i do
believe if we work
hard enough towards them there can be
silver linings to anything
no matter how bad it is and a silver
lining was i looked at myself and i you
know i'd wanted to go to medical school
but i thought i'm too old why because i
was 25 right like that's not too old
right but i i thought it was or i
couldn't leave my job because i was
making a good income and and if i went
to medical school i'm not gonna i'm
gonna pay and you know all these things
were in my head and people were saying
to me you're too old you can't walk away
from your job and it's gonna cost there
were so many things that i realize like
don't matter i'm like look i'm i have my
life and i'm i'm you know healthy enough
that i can go do what i want to do now
go do those things
right and it was actually quite helpful
to me and decided i'm gonna leave my job
and even though i haven't taken a single
pre-med course i'm gonna go apply and
you know it led me to to feel emboldened
but i had to get to a place where i
could see myself as a worthwhile and
capable person that's how i saw myself
before
his suicide but there was a whole period
of time when i didn't see myself that
way and it was really other people both
personally and professionally that were
sort of for me a bridge to a place i was
not going to be able to get on my own
and i think that's the case for many of
us and when people don't have access to
people who care about them people who
can help them
you know we unfortunately there's a lot
of secondary tragedies that come of that
because we're interconnected as human
beings and we are not
kind enough and helpful enough they you
know i write about like compassion
community and humanity and these basic
principles that i think we should be
following because i don't think they're
rocket science i think they're simple
yet we don't follow them and then we're
not there for each other in ways that i
think we want to think that we are right
but we often we're not living that in
the world around us
you